le coup de gueule de la chanteuse bébert
et que ça vous connaissez béret que ça
pas du tout mais deux jeunes connaissent
et puis vous parlez moi philosophie qui
est pourtant magnifique à regarder comme
elle est comme elle est ravissante
elle a été jugée trop grosse par les
couturiers alors qu'elle ne fait qu une
taille 40 on vous explique tout ça
bébert et que ça une pop star américaine
nommée aux emmy awards
donc c'est normal elle passe quelques
coups de fil à des stylistes pour lui
demander de leur prêter une tenue en vue
de la prochaine cérémonie
le problème c'est évidemment ils
auraient tous ont refusé en cause sa
taille un peu trop grosse lors qu'elles
ne portent que c'est superbe
oui et en plus elles portent que du 40
donc c'est un peu étonnant alors bon
alors tout cas c'est ce qu'elle dit
alors si elle dit vrai évidemment c'est
inadmissible d'autant que c'est pas très
malin économiquement puisque plus de 68%
des femmes américaine porteraient du 44
et plus
donc voilà vous avez entendus selon une
étude 68% des femmes américaines se
situe au delà du 44 c'est 40 % pour les
françaises donc finalement ils se
hissent affair marché qui est le marché
de la femme moyenne entre guillemets
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
nathalie ben moi je la trouve déjà
ravissante avec ses formes bon c'est
vrai qu'elle nous dit être un 40 mais je
verrais plutôt 1,4244 et l'oeil de
l'expert mais sans rien me fait même
penser un peu à la marilyn monroe de
notre époque mais moi je pense peut-être
que si on n'a pas voulu prêter une robe
je pense c'est parce qu'elle a mauvais
caractère
avec quoi il n'a rien à voir avec des
formes aux autres d'accord elle doit
avoir un très très mauvais caractère et
vous voyez ça à quoi pardonnez moi mais
ma she pas chanter sans voile ça c'est
une petite blonde donc le bordel qu'est
ce qu'on en pense même deux de ses
marques qui dès qu'ils décident de ne
pas parce que de ne pas prêter un
vêtement parce qu'ils estiment que là
qu'elle ne représente pas la femme
idéale selon leurs critères damien bah
moi je comprends que certaines marques
ne veuille pas lui prêter un certain
habib ben oui parce qu'une marque a le
droit de manager son image comme elle le
souhaite vous savez les grammy awards
c'est tout simplement entre 25 et 30
millions de téléspectateurs aux états
unis c'est un truc
ce serait dégradant de prod2 prêter une
robe à une femme qui fait plus de qui
fait du 40 ou plus pour certains mais
ces montants levés c'est honteux on est
d'accord mais force est de reconnaître
que pour certaines marques
oui c'est dégradant qu'une femme qui
fasse du 40 portent leurs habits
aujourd'hui on est dans la publicité
cela m attention non mais je ne
cautionne pas forcément mais c'est en
tout cas la réalité c'est que les
marques aujourd'hui dans les publicités
en tout cas dans ce genre de vitrine
mondiale
elle préfère avoir une sorte d'utopie de
silhouette parfaite pour mettre en avant
leurs produits et au final ça se
comprend c'est ma raison mais c'est le
monde à l'envers là c'est le monde à
l'envers j'hallucine parce que elle est
dans les médias sur les réseaux sociaux
de train de piailler pourquoi parce
qu'elle n'a pas de cadeaux madame les
cadeaux c'est à noël
madame bébert et que ça est en train de
dire les marques ne m'habille vous écris
parce que c est pourquoi on les tapis
rouges de ce genre de cérémonies comme
les grammy awards ont de toutes les
vedettes toutes les stars on leur prédit
d'ailleurs déjà rien c'est même la
personne ne la connaît sur lui même le
seul chat ou dans la fal utilité puisque
quand elles font le tapis rouge on leur
demande ont leur nom leur parle pas de
leur métier on leur parle de des
vêtements qu'elles portent donc là vous
êtes un peu il faut que je suis pour
cent des américains porte du 44 vous
l'avais dit il ya plein de magasins pour
n ya pas de soucis à nouveau disque
allait s'avérer dans les rues comme tout
le monde pourquoi hurler parce qu'on ne
lui fait pas de cadeau non mais il a
raison c'est quand même aussi mais je
trouve quand même gonflé parce que en
l'occurrence on suivra fait rempart
contre
[Applaudissements]
non mais là non on pointe du doigt un
vrai problème c'est à dire la
représentativité de la femme dans les
médias et là en l'occurrence c'est parce
qu'elle ne correspond pas à ce que les
médias imagine que doit être une femme
parfaite qu'on se lève un problème
et en plus ce qui est dramatique c'est
damien tu dis mais laissons les marques
choisir la silhouette de rêve comme si
sa silhouette était dégradante
comme si je suis désolé en plus aller
parler je sais pas où est ce qu'on met
le curseur pour grosse mais 40 42 44
c'est pas grosse et au nom de lui ça
dans la tête on est venu dans la tête
des jeunes filles
attention si vous ressembler à ça on ne
pourra pas vous habillez vous est grosse
vous êtes en dehors des clous dans un
contexte maudit société inclusive
soyez qui vous voulez on est contre la
grossophobie on a une super société sauf
que les marques le pratiquer on sait
qu'à des marques de prêt-à-porter en
france notamment qui refuse de mettre au
delà du 40 42 grand maximum donc ces
femmes là ne peuvent pas s'habiller par
contre un homme de paix du 48 du 50 ans
voir ça messieurs c'est un bon mangeur
c'est très sympa par contre une femme à
attention qu'elle rentre dans les clous
faux paquets de cheveux blancs sinon
elle se dit gless el jahedh négliger
vous avez raison pointé du doigt le
double langage et abusivement d'un homme
qui a les cheveux blancs c'est poivre et
sel c'est sympa le bidon c'est un bon
mangeur c'est un bon vivant
mais une femme tout de suite c'est tout
de suite aux rites donc voila ce genre
de discours est on va dire je suis
démagogues mais c'est la réalité je
pense sûrement un très mauvais message
dites moi ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag c'est que des haltes est-ce que
vous estimez que comme comme damien et
thibaut klein rachetée elle-même ses
fringues ou bien que effectivement là on
soulève un vrai problème qui est celui
de la représentation de la femme dans
les médias et de ce qu'elle devrait être
soi-disant la femme parfaite avec un
corps soit disant parfait en tout cas si
on vous prête une robe soyez sûr qu'elle
soit votre taille tout de même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]